Welcome.
We're with the Master and the disciple the moment a teacher refuses to teach a single doctrine until his student swears to five conditions of secrecy whose fifth name's the political stake.
Do not mention me to your father.
The pact of Allah is the key religion under it is sacred.
The same act without it is stolen.
So if you are joining us today, your mission for this deep dive is to step directly into a, well, a profoundly high stakes encounter.
Yeah, it really is.
We are looking at a historical and theological text that details an exchange between an elder scholar, the elder Persian voice in this tradition, and a young man, a disciple seeking spiritual truth.
Exactly.
And we're gonna decode the true meaning of discipline here.
We'll explore why secrecy and a really strict covenant are viewed as the ultimate gatekeepers to spiritual knowledge.
and why acting without them supposedly changes the very nature of a pious deed.
Okay, let's unpack this because the setup here is intense.
Very intense.
We have a young man practically begging to be a servant to this master just to learn the inward realities of his faith.
But the scholar stops him completely and sets a massive precondition.
He does.
The scholar introduces this concept he calls
Allah's accustomed way, because within the worldview of this text, spiritual knowledge isn't something you can just get all at once.
The elder Persian voice points out a biological reality.
The creator doesn't bring creatures into this world as fully grown adults.
Right, they arrive as infants.
Exactly.
They're small, entirely ignorant, and completely dependent.
And the scholar applies this directly to the young man's spiritual state.
He argues that we are all born as spiritual infants.
And an infant can't process solid food, they can only process milk.
So demanding advanced spiritual truths immediately is like trying to feed a steak to a newborn.
Which, I mean, on a practical level makes total sense.
Yeah, the tradition insists on a graduated ladder.
You have to grasp basic history, submit to the outward law, learn the inner interpretation, and only then can you glimpse the ultimate realities.
But the narrative quickly moves away from that gentle metaphor of spiritual nursing into a really rigid framework.
It definitely pivots.
The master tells the disciple he has to agree to five strict conditions of secrecy before a single lesson begins.
And the first four focus on the rhythm of their relationship.
Do not neglect anything entrusted to you.
Do not conceal anything from the master.
Do not come looking for him uninvited.
Yeah, do not speak out of turn.
Those govern the mechanics of trust.
But the 5th condition is the heaviest.
Do not mention me to your father.
I don't buy that yet.
Five conditions for a secret not yet told sounds like loyalty testing.
I get that.
It almost reads like a modern day cult leader isolating a new recruit from their support system.
Looking at it through a modern lens, that isolation is an immediate red flag.
But
The text frames this entirely differently.
It places it squarely within a context of physical survival.
Survival.
Yeah.
The narrative reveals the young man's father is not just an average guy.
He is a well-known leader of a rival community.
And crucially, this community has explicitly rejected the imam.
I see.
And in this tradition, the imam is the sole source of true, divinely sanctioned knowledge.
So this is the political stake.
If the son eagerly runs home and tells his father about this new spiritual path, the father's ideological allegiances would compel him to expose the scholar.
Oh man.
So premature disclosure wouldn't just cause a family argument.
No, it could destroy the scholar's entire mission.
It could potentially cost lives.
These conditions are framed as necessary protocols of survival in a deeply hostile environment.
And we really can't just view this as a teacher wanting a quiet, distraction-free classroom.
Not at all.
If we assume this is just pedagogical fussiness, you know, a teacher trying to create an aura of mystique around himself, that 5th condition about the father makes absolutely no sense.
Exactly.
If the goal was just effective teaching, the 5th condition would be a massive overreach.
You don't demand a student deceive their own family just to improve their study habits.
The scholar is actually enforcing a specific theological doctrine of prudential concealment.
He goes so far as to instruct the young man that he must not physically distance himself from his father.
Wait, really?
He has to stay close.
He has to.
Pulling away or acting rebellious would immediately invite suspicion.
The disciple must remain in the home, respect his father, and please him outwardly, all while ferociously guarding his innermost beliefs in secret.
That is heavy.
And the text claims direct scriptural authorization for this.
In the Quran, in the chapter of the family of Imran, verse 28, using the translation by Marmaduke Pickthall, there is an instruction that believers should not take disbelievers as friends in preference to believers.
The verse concludes that whoever does this has no connection with Allah, with one major exception, unless you but guard yourselves against them, taking, as it were, security.
Taking security.
That phrase fundamentally shifts what is happening here.
It really does.
It takes what looks like deceit and reframes it as a sanctioned tactical
Yes.
Taking security serves as the textual root for the scholar's demand.
From the perspective of this tradition, this concealment under duress is an act of profound loyalty.
Because he's playing a role.
Exactly.
The disciple is maintaining visible filial forms, playing the devoted son, specifically to protect the invisible bond he is forming with the master.
The commander of the faithful, peace be upon him, articulated the mechanics of this internal state perfectly.
What did he say?
In his preserved aphorisms, he observed that the tongue of the believer is behind his heart, and the heart of the hypocrite is behind his tongue.
The tongue behind the heart.
So the believer actually reflects before acting.
Yes, the heart assesses the political and physical danger.
If the environment is safe and the speech is good, the heart permits disclosure.
And if it's dangerous, the heart demands silence.
Precisely.
The 5 conditions are designed to forcefully build this exact architecture inside the young disciple.
The first two train his heart to safely hold a heavy trust.
The next two train his tongue to remain completely immobilized.
Until the heart signals readiness.
Yeah.
And the 5th condition makes the entire exercise literal.
It places the ultimate guard against the closest possible threat.
A father who would in complete good faith to his own rival beliefs, betray the secret.
But let me pose a question from the perspective of the young man sitting in that room.
He is about to endure immense psychological strain, living a dual life under his father's roof.
If he is doing all of this, shouldn't his internal sincerity be enough?
How do you mean?
Well, if he genuinely wants to be a good person and is seeking truth with a pure heart, shouldn't his pious actions just count on their own merit, regardless of all these strict conditions?
I mean, sincerity is treated as the ultimate finish line in a lot of modern spirituality, but reading sincerity alone as sufficient collides directly with the scholar's precondition.
It does.
Yeah.
Early in the narrative, the scholar lays down a rigid sequence regarding how deeds are weighed.
He states that knowledge is of no benefit
upon.
Action is of no benefit until it is accepted, and Allah accepts only sincerity.
Okay, so sincerity is the absolute baseline.
You cannot even enter the conversation without it.
Right.
But you are saying the text argues it is still not enough on its own.
Exactly.
Sincerity is strictly required, but entirely insufficient on its own.
To anchor this, the text relies on the prophetic standard.
The Prophet, peace and blessings of Allah be upon him and his family, established this dynamic in a foundational tradition about migrations.
The migrations.
Yes, he taught that actions are judged by intentions.
Whoever migrates for Allah and His messenger, their migration is credited to that divine reality.
But whoever migrates for worldly gain or simply to follow someone they want to marry, their migration is credited only to that worldly goal.
So the physical act is exactly the same to anyone watching.
Completely identical.
But the invisible intention beneath it determines if it has any spiritual weight whatsoever.
The Persian master is utilizing this gatekeeping principle.
Sincerity is the filter for whether an act can even be considered.
However, the narrative shows that even raw sincerity has to be placed within a specific formal structure to be valid.
Which brings us into the disciples' actual trial.
He accepts the burden, agrees to the secrecy, and then enters this grueling phase.
He's assigned outward tasks, but given absolutely no inner meaning to attach to them.
He doesn't even know where the scholar physically lives.
Yeah, still he perseveres.
And when they finally reunite after this trial, the young disciple is so overwhelmed with relief that he throws himself to the ground, prostrating in gratitude.
And the scholar immediately tells him to stop.
The scholar's correction there is incredibly revealing.
He tells the young man that offering gratitude before the deed is actually completed invites suspicion of insincerity.
Because he's performing the aesthetics of piety before doing the actual work.
Exactly.
It's A psychological trap.
And it's only after the young man absorbs this final correction
that the master finally reveals the central secret of their tradition.
And this is the pivot of the whole narrative.
The scholar reveals that there is a singular key to religion, a dividing line that renders an action
either entirely sacred or entirely profane.
He illustrates this using a stark analogy, the distinction between marriage and fornication.
If you strip away the social and legal context, the physical act is exactly the same.
What differentiates A permitted sacred union from a forbidden one is solely the formality of the marriage rite.
It's the covenant that places the act under Allah's name.
We see that identical logic in the rules surrounding permitted and forbidden animals, you can have two animals with the exact same biology, but the meat you are permitted to eat is distinguished from the forbidden meat entirely by the ritual slaughter.
The physical protein is the same.
It is placing the act under the name of Allah that alters its spiritual status.
And the scholar defines this transformative key as the pact of Allah.
Taking this pact confirms a person's rights and provides A spiritual safeguard.
He introduces 1/3 analogy here, referring to it as the rope of Allah upon his earth.
The rope.
Yeah.
This imagery is drawn directly from the chapter of the family of Imran, verse 103, which commands believers to hold fast altogether to the rope of Allah and not to be divided.
The rope grasped together.
That makes sense.
It's what binds A fragmented people back into one single cohesive body.
Precisely.
To take the pact is to literally grasp that rope.
Grasping the rope reattaches the individual to the unbroken chain through which divine protection flows.
And at this exact moment in the narrative, having understood the stakes, the noble oath of allegiance is finally taken by the young disciple.
The pact of Allah is the key religion.
Under it is sacred.
The same act without it is stolen.
Yes.
Without that specific oath, without that formal bond of allegiance to the imam, possessing or utilizing the knowledge of the inner interpretation is considered theft.
True knowledge is the property of the imam.
Giving him allegiance is the mechanism of paying the rightful owner his due.
This sounds like wordplay.
How is this different from saying the same prayer counts when our side prays it?
Because from the outside, an observer would just see this as classic sectarian gatekeeping.
It looks like that, sure.
Like you were just drawing a boundary and saying our club is holy, your club is not.
But the text argues it is
literal mechanics of spiritual ownership, not just tribal cheerleading.
The 6th Imam provided A fascinating, highly mathematical teaching to illustrate this.
The apple teaching, right?
Yeah.
He asks us to imagine a man who steals 5 apples.
The man then gives those five stolen apples to an old woman for charity.
Okay.
In his own mind, the man is doing spiritual accounting.
He calculates that an act of charity earns 50 rewards and the initial theft costs him five sins.
Therefore, he expects a net profit of 45 rewards.
Wait, if he is giving those apples to someone who is genuinely starving, he expects that the ultimate good of feeding her outweighs the initial crime of the theft.
He thinks the universe grades on a curve.
Exactly.
But the 6th Imam corrects his math entirely.
When the man stole the apples, he earned 5 sins.
When he handed them to the old woman for charity, he did not gain 50 rewards.
He actually gained another five sins.
Wait, 0 rewards.
Even if she needed the food, just because he handed them over.
Zero.
Because he propagated the forbidden into an innocent person's hand.
The final calculation is 10 sins and 0 rewards.
Wow, I mean that is incredibly strict.
The logic is that an act of charity requires the transfer of ownership.
You cannot transfer the ownership of something you do not legally possess.
Therefore, piety performed without allegiance operates on the exact same mechanic.
I see.
If you perform a religious act without having first taken the covenant, the act itself is stolen and a stolen act cannot be sanctified regardless of how outwardly beautiful or helpful it appears.
This is where it gets really interesting.
Because taking the oath transforms this entire process from a private, warm feeling in your chest into a formal public transaction with the owner of religion.
It does.
It ceases to be just a mentoring session between a student and a teacher in a hidden room.
The Quran confirms this elevation of the oath.
In the chapter of the conquest, verse 10, the text states, verily those who swear allegiance unto thee swear allegiance only unto Allah.
The hand of Allah is above their hands.
The hand above theirs.
Yes.
When the young man places his hand in the hand of this Persian stranger to swear the oath, the transaction physically bypasses the scholar entirely.
It lands directly on the hand above his.
The transaction is fundamentally with the owner of the religion.
And until that specific formal transaction happens, the baseline sincerity we discussed earlier cannot fully actualize.
You can mean well, but you are still operating with stolen goods.
Exactly.
The master Baghdad, the early voice of the inward path, captured this tension brilliantly.
He taught that sincerity is a heavily guarded secret between the servant and his lord.
The recording angel doesn't know what to write it down and the devil doesn't know what to corrupt it.
But he added a crucial caveat.
Whoever's act is owned by another cannot make it sincere.
You simply cannot transact a stolen secret.
Because you do not hold the title to it.
Exactly.
You cannot sincerely give away the apples and you cannot sincerely offer a prayer if you have not established your right to hold them through the covenant.
The act holds 0 spiritual value unless it is fully owned by the actor.
And the text argues it's not owned by the actor until the rightful owner has been formally paid his due.
That due is the pact of Allah.
So how does this invisible internal architecture apply to the outward law?
How does this change the way a believer views the physical rituals they have to perform every single day?
Well, the scholar lays out the outward law as a graduated ladder of discipline stacked by the frequency of the requirement.
At the very base, you have ritual purity and the daily prayer, which must happen five times every day.
Yeah.
Above that is the fast, which occurs for one month yearly.
Above that are the alms, required once yearly, then the pilgrimage, required once a lifetime.
But sitting at the absolute top, encompassing and validating all the steps below it is allegiance to the imam with every single breath.
The logic is that the most continuous, unceasing obligation is the one that gives weight and meaning to all the intermittent obligations.
I have to concede my earlier doubt.
When we started, I really thought those five conditions of secrecy
were just a manipulative loyalty test to isolate the kid.
Yeah, it looks like that at first glance.
But looking at this ladder, the framework is incredibly consistent.
The outward rituals, the physical fasting, the mechanics of praying are designed to train the limbs into habits of submission.
Exactly.
And the five conditions of secrecy are doing the exact same thing to the soul.
They train the invisible self into the heavy habit of holding the secret safely.
Both are demanding forms of the law.
makes perfect sense of the language we use.
How so?
The word disciple literally comes from discipline and discipline comes from submitting to the law.
The title of the text, The Master and the Disciple, is teaching exactly what the book teaches.
That's a great way to put it.
The seeker only earns the title of disciple when he fully accepts the discipline.
The discipline is the mechanism of the law working on the heart, and the covenant is what ensures that the entire arrangement remains sacred rather than reverting to a stolen act.
It's a complete transformation.
Yeah, it is.
Which brings us to the emotional climax of the young man's journey.
The Persian scholar recites the oath.
The disciple repeats the words, binding his life to it.
And the text describes the young man's eyes streaming with tears in that moment.
Because he finally understands the weight of it.
Yeah, he understands with absolute certainty that he has finally entered the protected party of Allah.
The party of Allah.
Yes.
That specific phrase is drawn from the chapter of the table spread, verse 56, which declares, and whoever takes Allah and his messenger and those who believe as his protectors, then verily the party of Allah, they are the victorious.
Man, that's powerful.
That verse represents the threshold the disciple finally crosses.
Before taking the oath, he was just an isolated young man from the town asking dangerous questions, carrying the crushing psychological weight of his father's rival sectarian alignment entirely alone.
Yeah, totally isolated.
But the second he finishes repeating the formula, his reality shifts.
He is protected, he is victorious, he is tethered to the rope, he is no longer alone.
The pact of Allah is the key religion, under it is sacred.
The same act without it is stolen.
This leaves us with a profound lens to turn inward.
We live in an era that worships total transparency, where broadcasting every thought and feeling is viewed as the highest form of authenticity.
Yet this text argues the exact opposite, that true sacredness requires boundaries, intense discipline, and a heavily guarded heart.
So for you, listening to this journey of the disciple, consider the foundation of your own actions.
Which of your most repeated acts of piety, whether it is your daily prayer, your giving of charity, or your fasting, has been performed under a covenant never consciously taken?
And what would it cost this week to ask whose hand the act is paid into?
A vital reflection for anyone examining the roots of their own path.
Thank you for analyzing this intense historical text with us today.
Thank you for joining us in this deep dive.
Stay curious and take care.